قرر البرلمان الليبي استدعاء حكومه فتح
باشاغه لمسالتها بشان مصروفات ونفقات عام
2022 واستجوابها عن اعمالها منذ تكليفها
وذلك قبل مصادقته على ميزانيه هذا العام
واوضح المتحدث الرسمي للبرلمان عبد الله
لاحق ان اغلبيه اعضاء البرلمان طالبوا
باستدعاء الحكومه التي يوافقوا على
تعيينها قبل عام تحتسم حكومه الاستقرار
ومن المرجح ان يطلب اعضاء البرلمان من
رئيس الحكومه فتحي باشاغا خلال جلسه
المسائله التي لم يتحدد موعدها بعد تقريرا
مفصلا عن مصروفات الحكومه منذ توليها
مهامها في مارس العام الماضي واوجه انفاق
الاموال التي حصلت عليها الى جانب تقييم
ادائها وعملها
من بنغازي ضو الينا مراسله عربيه محمد
مسعود اهلا بك محمد اذا محمد استدعاء
حكومه باشاغ ومسالتها من البرلمان هل ياتي
في سياق اجراءات روتينيه تقادمه صلاحيات
البرلمان كما هو معروف ام ان ذلك يشيء
بتجاوزات ماليه ربما تكون قد ارتكبت في
العام الماضي
وكل المشاهدين بالف خير بمناسبه شهر رمضان
المباركه هو امر كان متوقعا منذ فتره خاصه
بعد يعني نشوب خلافات بين اعضاء مجلس
النواب حول حكومه باشا اغا والصلاحيات
الممنوحه للحكومه ونتحدث ايضا في عدم
قدرتها اي بدا هذا الخلاف منذ عدم قدرته
على الدخول الى العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس
وايضا بالتالي عدم الاعتراف الدولي
بالحكومه وعدم تمكنها من وضع يدها على
ايرادات النفط او التحكم في عوائد النفط
المدخل الرئيسي
اللي قتل الدين او للدوله بصفه عامه تاتي
هذه المطالب التي تقدم بها عدد كبير من
اعضاء مجلس النواب اكثر من 35 النائبه
تقدموا بهذا طلب من اجل استدعاء رئيس
الحكومه ومساءلته فيما يتعلق بمصروفات
الحكومه والحساب الختامي الذي تم صرفه من
الميزانيه سمدت في العام الماضي للحكومه
بواقع 89 مليار دينار ليبي واوجه الصرف
وابواب الصرف في هذه الميزانيه خاصه بان
يعني الباب الاول المتعلق بالمرتبات واجور
المواطنين متحكم به من قبل الحكومه
المتواجده في العاصمه الليبيه اطراف حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه رغم نيله حكومه السيد بشار
غاليه الثقه للشرعيه من مجلس النواب
وبالتالي كل هذه النقاط هي يعني نقاط
جوهريه واساسيه يستند عليها عدد كبير من
اعضاء المجلس النواب بان ما الحقيقه جاء
بعد تعهد السيد بشاغه لدخوله الى طرابلس
وبالتالي يحق لهم محاسبته الان على
المصروفات بالدرجه الاولى وايضا ضعف اداء
الحكومه وعدم تمكنها من الدخول لذلك
الواضحه التي سببت في يعني هذا الامر
واستدعاء الحكومات